hi there Steve here continuing on my
Korean challenge at five o'clock today I
have a skype conversation in Korean
lined up I didn't get that much done
today play some hockey this morning and
over the next 3-4 days I'm going to be
probably traveling with my wife maybe on
Vancouver Island or up to Whistler play
a bit of golf because she's having a
bunion operation next week and once that
happens she won't be able to play golf
for quite a while so in order to prepare
for that I'm gonna do some videos in a
variety of languages and get them up um
now just comment on this now I said we
would do you know captions whatever but
it is an awful lot of work instead what
I'm going to do is I'm going to tell you
what I'm going to say in these different
languages i'm going to say more or less
the same thing in all of them is so that
you'll know roughly what I'm talking
about and on my languages I kind of sort
of feel I have five languages that I can
turn on it will which is English of
course English French Japanese Mandarin
and Spanish they're kind of in declining
order of proficiency then I get to other
languages which I can also more or less
turn on it well but I don't do quite as
well and I'm more aware of my mistakes
that would be German and Swedish in and
probably Cantonese in Italian and and
maybe Portuguese maybe Russian is in
that group so that's another six and
then there are those languages where I
would have to really spend a couple of
days warming up to get back in the mood
because my brain is running on Korean
right now and that would be you know the
Slavic Ukrainian polish check and of
course Korean and Romanian I would
probably need a good week to get up to a
level where I could actually say
something in Romanian so I'm probably
going to go in that order except that
i'm going to start with russian because
the first person who asked for other
languages rolled in Russian I think it's
a female and so that's what I'm going to
start with the message is that the the
purpose of these challenges is
not that you set yourself a goal I'm
going to be fluent or I'm going to you
know I'll be wonderful in the language
because we can't in a way we can control
that what we can control is our level of
activity and I've always believed that
the most important thing well I say it
all the time in language learning is
attitude time on task and the ability to
notice and they are connected the better
our attitude the more time we spend the
more things we noticed so the thing that
we can control better than anything else
in a way is that time we spend on the
task that's why I link for example we
measure activity more than anything else
and so the purpose of the challenge is
to make it provide some incentive for
people to focus their energies on a
specific language to try to maintain
their activity index that link or to
create so many links or to read so many
words so that that they are comfortable
at the end of it that they have put in a
sufficient amount of time to really make
you know a breakthrough or a big step
forward and if they do put that time in
into meaningful and effective activities
they will make that major improvement I
know it from experience but some may
progress more in some aspects or another
aspect so setting your self specific
sort of accomplishment goals achievement
goals that the language is more
difficult setting yourself activity
goals makes a lot of sense so that's
what I'm going to do and i'm going to
say those things more or less in these
other languages and i hope that
satisfies you but and i hope i can
maintain one a day if i get some of
these foreign language ones in the
system in reserve so to speak while I'm
traveling ok bye for now
this is hope oh hi everybody diggity
vittoria yeah welcome hey McCoy yeah she
went away Fuquan should take a widow
well why do you talk a little when I
look at this with that do that lover
that when Tyrion would look great